después de una intensa noche de
bombardeos en su mí en el noreste de
ucrania los trabajadores de emergencia
limpian lo que queda de las casas el
ministerio de defensa ruso asegura que
sus tropas atacaron 60 sitios militares
ucranianos en la madrugada después de
que moscú iniciará el lunes por la noche
una nueva ofensiva en la región de
bombas
la operación en el este de ucrania fue
lanzada tal y como fue anunciado desde
el principio para liberar completamente
a las repúblicas de donges y lugansk en
la región oriental es mayoritariamente
de habla rusa y los separatistas
respaldados por moscú llevan ocho años
luchando contra las fuerzas ucranianas
el ejército ruso tomó este martes la
ciudad oriental de cree mina el
gobernador regional dijo que las tropas
ucranianas se habían retirado de la
ciudad las fuerzas rusas están atacando
ahora las posiciones ucranianas a lo
largo de los 480 kilómetros de la línea
del frente regis que ocupó a los
ocupantes rusos han intensificado las
operaciones ofensivas a lo largo de toda
la línea de contacto los principales
esfuerzos del enemigo se centran en
romper la defensa de las tropas
ucranianas en han sido mis cursos esta
hospedería de la región de doñetsk los
residentes fueron evacuados antes del
nuevo asalto las autoridades ucranianas
instaron a los habitantes de donbass a
huir hacia el oeste aunque suspendieron
las evacuaciones por tercer día
consecutivo de las ciudades en primera
línea debido a los continuos combates